Hi. Welcome to Introduction to Health Informatics.
I'm Mark Braunstein, and unlike your other Georgia Tech professors,
I was trained as a physician.
However, I came to medical school after MIT,
interested in applying computers to
medicine and ended up starting a few companies based on that work.
I started the last of these at Georgia Tech's Incubator,
the Advanced Technology Development Center.
And when it was acquired,
I joined the faculty to help create a program in Health Informatics.
This course is about Health Informatics,
which is the many applications of computing to the delivery of health care.
Since the 1950's, when computers could first store and process large amounts of data,
software developers have seen health care as a fertile domain.
Electronic medical records systems date back to at least the early 1960.
That's when Akron Children's Hospital and IBM created HIS,
the first computer based hospital patient information system.
Here, you can see it being tested by a nurse.
Another application is clinical decision support systems.
These guide physicians as they deliver care based on
scientific evidence and they date back to at least 1972, when work began on mycin.
Mycin, was a program for the optimal selection of antibiotics to treat infections.
Ambulatory electronic medical records systems for use outside of hospitals,
began a bit earlier.
In fact, as you can see here,
I oversaw the development and did some of the programming of one of these early EMRs,
starting in 1970 at the Medical University of South Carolina in Charleston.